okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and as you guys know we have the podcast
here on marvel explain but what we've
done is we've changed things up and so
we have a discussion or kind of debate
of sorts so we talk about two characters
which one would win in a particular
scenario that we lay out and that Dave
chooses the characters for that video
that debate you can find on Benny's
channel comic story in which there'll be
a link here on the screen and in the
description and make sure you guys check
that out because they're pretty fun
basically it's it's based upon our raw
knowledge of the two superheroes that
David picks and we basically create a
fanfiction on the spot this week was
Batman vs Nick Fury you guys gonna watch
the video to find out what's going on
but it's it was a really fun video was
really entertaining and I think you guys
are really gonna like it but uh one of
the parts today yeah we're not gonna
tell you guys here was it came out on
top but um but anyway in this video in
this podcast we're gonna be talking
about the casting choices that Marvel
has going on with regards to films
they're not just Marvel black Fox and
character that have been chosen so we're
we talking about Ben Affleck as Batman
we'll be talking about Josh Brolin to
Stano sand and Tom Hardy or who was the
other guy that they wanted for Doctor
Strange it was Tom Hardy at somebody
else I don't see nothing of Doctor
Strange Oh what what likes you if you're
up for it and we can give a big spoiler
warning in front of it
but did you read the suppose at first 20
minutes of Avengers 2 no I think you
know that was online oh yeah oh my god
well we'll go over that towards the end
of the podcast if you want now its
production script so it couldn't get all
changed around but this is what what
supposedly has been revealed Wow okay so
so Ben Affleck alright so we got to talk
about him so my thoughts my pack on Ben
Affleck yeah Pat flame I thought I'm Ben
Affleck he is really good in some rules
like in the town he was amazing
well he was right it was amazing at the
town yeah he was terrible as daredevil
but here's a question was Ben Affleck
bad in daredevil because of the writing
or because he's just bad at playing
superheroes yeah it was the writing in
the production
I'd say yeah because if you pay real
close attention to his acting his acting
is spot-on yeah it's just
they didn't really make his character
believable the way it was written
well and I agree with you on that but
there's also a certain extent of if Ben
Affleck had read the daredevil books
ahead of time and really known more
about daredevil no I don't know about
its history with daredevil cuz I story
and it wasn't a big fan of a Ben Affleck
it's time but uh overall I would like to
think that he could have at least
redeemed it to a certain extent if he
had done more daredevil research oh yeah
you know I don't know if you agree or
disagree Rob but well I will say the
director gave him a port direction there
is a certain amount that he could have
come back and fixed that with well
alright so so daredevil daredevil is a
really interesting character in Marvel
Comics like one he's really really dark
like Matt Murdock is a dark character in
Marvel Comics I mean that's that's the
whole basis behind him like whenever you
read daredevil comics it's very similar
to reading spawn comics in the sense
that the comics always take place down
in the bottom of Hell's Kitchen so it's
like these really dark and seedy comics
and there's not very much like joy to
them at all I mean there's really no
comedic element to it there is from time
to time especially we time I was his
sidekick I can't know what his name is
but there I guess is assisting god when
he's Matt Murdock the lawyer but as far
as him being the superhero like it's
it's dark and and even that continues
when Black Panther takes over the role
you know in the man with without fear or
whatever that comic was whenever that
line was when he takes over the role of
Black Panther it maintains the same
element as daredevil it maintains the
same elements so I felt like the way the
movie liked the way it looked in terms
of just being really dark was accurate I
mean that was really kind of how it was
supposed to be but the problem is that
watching the movie felt like reading a
Wolverine comic because there was so
much in termina log and daredevil
doesn't have that much inner monologue I
mean he has some to a degree but it's
not like where you're reading a
Wolverine comic and Wolverine is
constantly talking it's like Rorschach
from The Watchmen you know it's
different you know
Wolverine has three doesn't talk in
person very much it's all he doesn't he
really doesn't I'm he's usually arguing
people are saying he's gonna kill him so
you know if I see he was horrible and
daredevil but that he was good in the
town and he could be good in Batman but
here's the big debate that I have see
Marvel I think did a great thing because
they picked some big-name actors but
they weren't too big there's a bisl line
where an actor starts to stop
the role they're trying to cast into and
eventually you're watching that actor a
great example is and I loved this movie
edge of tomorrow I thought it was great
and I felt that what's his name Tom
Cruise's character had a great arc in
that movie but until at least until
halfway through it I was watching Tom
Cruise and I wasn't watching the
character yeah and it was halfway
through that I started kind of get a
feeling actually you know I'd like to
say that he started off as a character
II and turned into Tom Cruise cuz
conquers is always that like I always
know the answer can get out of the
impossible kind of a character and
that's and if the character kind of fell
into the way Tom Cruise typically acts
out his characters yeah he started out
as this coward and became this character
and that's one of the greatest arcs I've
ever seen him but once he started doing
that again I stopped seeing the
character and I started seeing Tom
Cruise mr. possible
no okay that was gonna be my question so
are you talking about you saw Tom Cruise
like I could I could see Tom Cruise like
being this person or I just thought like
a different version of Tom Cruise okay
Tom Cruise is a great example but was
another great example of I mean there's
certain actors that eventually you're
just watching them Liam Nielson Liam
Nelson is always the same character
you're watching Liam Nielson you're not
watching character he's supposed to be
yeah from going to you know taking he
was some random sex CIA CIA guy and then
he was some guy in the woods fighting
dogs with the same attitude and then is
then he was a marshal on a plane
drinking with the same attitude as
always liam nielsen you don't see him
portray anything else okay Pierce
Brosnan's the same way you always see
bond regardless of what you want to see
because because that's how he always
acts that like brutish guy who knows
everything more as British accent ever
I'm so glad you said that because have
you seen the Thomas Crown Affair yes
yeah and it was just bond the jump on in
his off hours exactly it's like a James
Bond movie about with Ben Affleck is now
he was good in the town and he can break
out of his mold but how often do you
just see Ben Affleck yeah you know when
he when he guest stars in chasing amy
and he was in you know what was that
crappy movie with him and lopez it was
just badass cameos it was Ben Affleck
again you know it's always the same same
guy who plays the same role in that
and that's what I'm worried about with
Batman that we're not gonna be able to
see past that applicant well just gonna
see that we're just gonna see that act
like we're not gonna see Batman but okay
but here's see here's the thing you have
to ask to though
like let's take Robert Downey jr. as
Tony Stark all right now if you met
Robert Downey jr. today or if you
imagine Robert Downey jr. seven years
ago do you think he would be pretty much
the exact same way that he is an Iron
Man yes but and Robert energy was kind
of in that same role but he's been to a
unique situation I can picture Robert
Downey jr. as Tony Stark before the
movie you started exactly I know and I
know the comic book version was a lot
duller and not like they've more adapted
it's a B the Robert Downey jr. version
but there was always those those play
boyish elements that Robert Downey jr.
is that was the perfect casting ever
okay well let me ask you Chris Evans
could you see Chris Evans as Captain
America no but I do now yeah pretty
popular had a following of a fan base
but they hadn't really become their
characters yet they hadn't become we're
just watching Chris Evans so when he
started being Captain America you're
like I can totally see Kathryn merica
now I think the real reason that I think
that Chris Evans was a good Captain
America was because they changed his
body type and they almost changed the
shape of his face in the beginning right
happy I think Chris Evans it does a good
Captain America because they picked
someone who almost is your Boy Scout guy
you know yeah like with the way he does
his hair and everything even when he was
like the super jock and those of them
like the romantic comedies he was still
kind of that all-american guy blond hair
muscular guy you know the barbel did a
good job and they didn't pick guys who
already act like okay let's say they
took Tom Cruise and made Tom Cruise
Captain America you wouldn't see Captain
America you would see Tom Cruise well
not only that it would've just been a
terrible choice I have Tom Cruise
playing they're just going how big can
we get the actors to be yeah oh we're
gonna get Ben Affleck okay cool
you know we're gonna get Gio whatever I
don't even know her name but apparently
she's big in her little circle you know
it's like they're just trying to get the
biggest it think
jesse eisenberg to be Lex Luthor I saw
that let's talk about the guy from
social network I mean I I saw does not
make him Lex Luthor what the hell is
that well that and I agree I agree with
you on that
I think Marvel made a decision in
picking characters who best can play the
role and let's see to me like that's
when it comes to Ben Affleck we haven't
seen a whole lot of superhero roles from
Ben Affleck I mean we saw daredevil and
that was really about it but but Ben
Affleck has a great track record - I
mean you look at what goodwill Hey Good
Will Hunting in the town of the two best
ones I could say he's done yeah but
every single round that we get Ben
Affleck we don't get the characters now
he can act and that's I'm hoping he
brings that to Batman well that's that's
that's what I'm saying and that's why I
brought up Robert Downey jr. because
when you looked at Robert Downey jr. is
like seven years ago even when he was
going through all his personal issues
and he look at Robert Downey jr. today
for the most part they're relatively the
same obviously he's not going to the
same kind of personal demons that he had
before so he's dealing with that
differently but the fact remains that
you could like seven years ago you could
see Robert Downey jr. playing iron man
like now you could definitely see Robert
Downey jr. playing iron man to me I
could see Ben Affleck playing Batman but
it depends on how Batman is written well
it also depends on one key factor how
much of Ben athletes face they're gonna
show if they put men epic on there and
we just see Bruce Wayne at the beginning
and maybe the ending and we see nothing
else but the bat mask then you could
definitely it will help with the
transition of it being Ben Affleck but
if we do like like the original Judge
Dredd was Sylvester Stallone where Judge
Dredd is known for the helmet but that
whole movie he did wear once yeah I
think the opening and that was it that
was it if we go that route then no
everyone's gonna see Ben Affleck and
they're not gonna care but but to see at
the same time though you also got to
consider this from like Fox's
perspective like and we had this
discussion I think last time you've got
the Marvel Cinematic Universe which I
think we can universally agree
hands-down are like the best Marvel
films are coming editor or WWE but
nonetheless like we you have the Marvel
Cinematic Universe where they have we
have like the best characters the some
of the best movies coming out of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe know you've
got Captain Captain America - which was
not just a great action movie and had
great like political themes and all
kinds of stuff you know well the reason
the reason why the Marvel wort universe
works so well is they make each
individual movie as an individual movie
yeah but it all don't try to do like
this but like the promise Piderman to is
this nothing but basically teasers for
every other movie yeah but that's a
debate in itself now all in itself why
Marvel is doing it right and no one else
is yeah you've got you've got this like
you've got these amazing movies that are
coming out for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and they say yes this movie
stands on its own but it's all going
towards a bigger picture there's gonna
be this great big huge pool of in this
is gonna take we don't care about
anything else and you're just gonna go
see an action movie you go watch Captain
America too and be perfectly fine you
could but the problem is that when you
have all these great movies coming out
of Marvel and then you've got Batman
coming out of Fox or coming out of WB
then they have to do what they can to
draw people in because right now
everybody is looking at the Marvel
Cinematic Universe oh yeah yeah I mean
like Christopher Nolan Christopher Nolan
did a great thing for Batman up until
the Dark Knight Rises because I thought
the Dark Knight Rises was okay but it
was no Dark Knight so you know it was he
took too many obscure elements and tried
to ground them in reality that's my
that's what I was going to say there's
two movies it worked with what he took
you know ok scarecrow is just a
psychiatrist with a mask who has the
formula yeah I could see that yeah why
would why would he walk around in a full
costume he's a businessman who's not
gonna just come out and walk around in a
big flowing green cloak god damn that
makes sense Bane suddenly being a guy
from halfway across the world who's been
mutilated and and the whole entire
cities just going down and no one caring
that movie just made no sense it was
okay now let's listen let's slide check
for a second let's talk about that so
Bane
alright and this is I guess you know
this would will talk about Vayne and Tom
Hardy later on but with Bane I didn't
think they did him justice in the end
like they just made him a henchman but
Bane was he had a classical education he
discovered Batman's identity and what
like like six months or something like
that like he was Bruce Wayne I mean like
no one else had been able to do that
yeah I mean they did it better than it
was before is George Clooney Batman oh
because that was just terrible that was
[ __ ] prisoners just like oh I'm
gonna walk out and basically ever been
done justice for bidc
is they did it the right Bane was in
Young Justice and it was kind of oh yeah
the young justice Bane I think it's
probably the best portrayal of Bane he
was the rightness is the day Missa tee
finally because they always they always
make him something else yeah well you
know he had the proper background he had
the proper power set everything it was
it was the finally know right babe yeah
I was I was kind of glad I was glad the
way they they did his character not
necessarily in the sense they made him
kind of like you know a thug more or
less like a hired thug that's really all
he was for Talia al Ghul was just a
hired thug oh yeah like you know but the
fact that that I like that they didn't
have like tubes and stuff sticking out
of him and he was just like I'm a really
strong guy like I like that element and
to me like the fight scene between him
and Batman and the sewers is one of the
greatest movie fight scenes that I've
seen in a long time like I love that
scene but to continue this sidetracking
here that's not what makes bane bane I
though is you know he's on par with
Batman and what always makes he's always
that lion because Batman even takes the
venom at some point ro it's that line up
I could be so much more powerful if I
just take this one drug and this is the
path that'll take me down I'll become
this big evil guy cuz Bane always just
like okay and the forever evil Arkham
war thing Bane helps everyone at got
them out he takes over Gotham II but he
wants to rule it in a militaristic kind
of nature he doesn't want a [ __ ] to be
Batman and there's always that with this
with that much strength and that
intelligence combined that's where
you're gonna go you just have too much
hmm and what Batman took the venom he
became a problem to it the venom is what
makes bane bane by removing the venom
just making him a really strong guy
first off you get rid of the fact that
he's so strong that he can lift
everything and just destroy Batman
what's your strength and secondly you're
now adding and it you removed one of the
core fact as a being Bane yeah you know
and the tubes did the tubes they've
gotten rid of in the main thing the
tubes are not like all over the place he
just slices them Bane's seen that as a
weakness and retracted them all down so
I mean that's not even a problem you
could if you're very easily reduced
venom and not bothered with that in that
last movie I did like the storylines
that they
picked and how they mix them together
okay I like they took nightfall in in
no-man's land
both of which I read so I understood
what was going on a little bit better
right uh I don't know if you've read
those benny-boy well I don't read no
man's lair
yeah no man's land it's long too like I
haven't read all of it but I've read
three of the four volumes that came out
Wow yeah I think they did a pretty good
job making it realistic but at the same
time I would have liked to see Gotham
suffer like a tremendous earthquake or
natural disaster instead of them being
held hostage there would be some way
like all the police force is walled into
this one location really yeah yeah this
you know nobody stays gone every not
certain to one location yeah no way they
would firfer now any reason but
especially in an area that a super
villains is superhero oh this seems like
a great idea to everyone in any way
we're way side Trek but yeah so Ben
Affleck playing Batman um I don't think
it'd be the worst casting choice but
again it depends on how he's written um
I'm kind of like I'm with you on this
one Benny if they if they say that if
they reveal Ben Affleck as Bruce Wayne
maybe like three or four times then we
will get pure acting just because we
won't see him we don't see his facial
mannerisms we won't see any of that
stuff it'll just be him as Batman
talking so he able to say also like
really really act so it depends on how
like all the writing and everything has
done it depends on the story you know I
know it's nice to be like Bruce Wayne
versus Superman I guess or something
like that or Batman versus Superman I'm
not wildly familiar with I don't know
and and and that's I'm not you know I'm
not sure what direction they're gonna
take this if at the end they're gonna be
allies or they meet for the first time I
don't know why you would make the movie
where Batman a Superman first meet a
versus movie as opposed to well that
every time the Batman a Superman first
meet is always a fight yeah it's always
the no one knows who he is characters
Superman's vu random alien they always
meet early on in their lifespan of being
superheroes
I mean it Justice League origins they
start fighting yeah but that's been done
to death like everybody everybody's done
it a million times I just have a cameo I
mean just have a you know I'm not really
sure what the role is or just has some
lis like where Clark Kent and Batman are
talking to each other I mean it could it
could be a sealing introduction with a
great story but you could put them both
in the movie just fine why are they
gonna fight yeah there's more than
enough villains have to come together
for well what I'm gonna guess is that at
this point
Bruce Wayne like like in The Dark Knight
Returns or Rises no oh look Frank Miller
okay but I'm gonna guess like in that
storyline Superman is gonna be working
for the government and pretty much comes
to Gotham when Batman has been around
for a while and has a reputation and
then somehow the government's going to
pit Superman up against Batman to try to
stop him from the discussion for an
entire another day when they start
revealing stuff of Man of Steel I've got
information on Avengers 2 guys why are
we speculating on
nobody cares about Batman vs Superman in
the moon okay so can we what you were
saying about the Batman thing you know
if they if they don't show his Ben
Affleck where I don't what I want to see
honestly is like how they did in
spider-man we know it's Andrew Garfield
but he wore the freakin mask when he was
spider-man mm-hmm okay I don't want to
see Tobey Maguire spider-man where every
five minutes the mask was being removed
yeah I it every five minutes it was oh
look it's Tobey Maguire yeah now the one
thing I will say is this from the
pictures that I've seen just in Ben
Affleck dresses Batman it actually looks
pretty impressive oh yeah he looks
really good et you know what I like that
costume better than the Nolan Batman
yeah
Nolan Batman was just wait
dark I didn't like the way it come
around it didn't yeah it was it was a
little it was a little it left some to
be desired but you know I think his head
though this is true I will say this
though Ben Affleck is a very capable
actor and if he's given the right role
he can be a force to be reckoned with in
Hollywood when it comes to playing a
character now whether or not this will
be one of those roles I don't know I
guess always have to kind of wait and
see but I'm really really hoping now
they're bringing some quality actors to
this film because this could this could
make or break you know the whole DC
movie franchise when it comes to this
point because oh it won't break it I'll
say that right now to the floor I mean
with two two of the biggest superheroes
that ever came out of DC I don't know
man I mean if they're two of the biggest
superheroes ever cuz you got Superman
and Batman are recognizable around the
world Marvel really only has spider-man
as a worldwide I recognize him character
in Captain America and Iron Man all
around the world to be recognized and
Professor Charles Xavier
definitely yeah I understand they are
two of the most recognizable Marvel came
after DC that's yeah they did I mean it
was it was well I mean if you want to
look at it that way timely adolescent
and yeah I mean this you're right but I
will grant you and say this Superman and
Batman are two of the biggest superhero
creations ever in the history of comic
books I mean I don't really know anybody
that would say that's not true but but
to me I mean you've got two of the
biggest names ever who were gonna be in
a single film together and if it turns
out to be total trash if it totally
tanks and it's got four percent on
Rotten Tomatoes I think people are just
gonna cut ties and just go for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and just say
the heck with it actually I think after
Man of Steel most people are already on
board with tomorrow said it wasn't that
bad you know boy we get a look at the
track record here we had Green Lantern
that was horrendous that was bad
okay we had the Olin verse that has now
been officially disassociated
disassociated from everything taken away
they never should have done then we have
Man of Steel which while being a good
movie is not the Superman everyone knows
it's its fans like me that knows the
modern-day Superman that recognize that
and submit didn't do much of the
destruction as more sod everything else
but the new 52 Superman which is kind of
what that was based around no one knows
no one knows him they all know him he's
the boy scout wearing his underwear on
the outside Superman all right so do you
think because you're the you're the DC
guy here do you think that they jumped
the gun by having by cuz remember the
last version of Superman anybody knew
was one Christopher Reeves and then
Superman Returns which was ever long and
then they just jumped a Superman killing
a person so this was if I remember
correctly this was the first time we
ever saw a movie where Superman killed a
guy do you think they jumped way too far
between the time when Superman would
never kill a person and the version when
he would do you think they should have
like filled some stuff in no no this
works because I mean even in the new 52
they went that route with it it was like
new PG - oh look now he'll do it if it's
needed and that's kind of that's kind of
the direction okay I was always just
kind of curious because I remember when
Superman would never kill a guy's like
there's always a better way you know to
kill I mean even like before all these
super powers like overpowered villains
there always was a better way for him
because he could always out strength
everybody like what like it was always
like a cop out because they'd be like oh
here's kryptonite here's kryptonite
here's kryptonite oh I'm strong anyways
like yeah the record we are completely
off of the actor choices we are we are
okay we really get back on track we need
to get back on so so can we agree that
Ben Affleck could very well do great at
this role but it really just kind of
boils down to how the story's written
yes but I do want to say this I'm hoping
he picked it cuz he really thinks he can
do a good Batman and not because someone
said do you want to be Batman II would
[ __ ] god I really yeah I hope that's not
the case because we could be looking at
we could be looking at a return to
George Clooney Batman's and that would
mean I really hope you can bring
something to the table and not just
hey guys um okay so let's segue into the
daredevil all right so let's like way
into Vincent D'Onofrio all right because
actually I meant to talk about this have
you guys heard about that no I've heard
about that
okay this in D'Onofrio has been cast to
play the role of kingpin and the
daredevil Netflix a little bit oh my god
come on guys you guys at home the moment
I see him kingpin kingpin was yeah yeah
he's the crime lord of New York City Oh
Vincent D'Onofrio yeah like he first I
think came to fame with Full Metal
Jacket when he went crazy kingpin is and
I was like what see that's that's what I
thought all right but here's here's the
deal like we've seen some changes in
terms of characters with the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and honestly I
wouldn't mind seeing a guy who doesn't
weigh you know 500 pounds and is like
500 pounds of solid muscle playing the
role of King I mean I don't mind I mean
to me that's that's not a huge character
change to me this like this is an offer
he was gonna have to be ruthless because
the kingpin was ruthless I mean he was
hardcore I hate this but Duncan did a
good King pit he was not bad yeah he
wasn't he wasn't bad but that ties into
the terrible nature of the daredevil
movie so yeah they're not getting in the
Netflix series yeah that's not gonna
happen now now now here's the deal if
Michael dark Lunken Michael Clarke
Duncan were alive I'm pretty sure Marvel
the Marvel Cinematic Universe would say
let's just bring this guy on yeah yeah
but um all right
all right so are you guys familiar with
kingpin at all like his history and
Marvel comic Lee I know he's primarily a
daredevil bad guy but he pops up in a
lot of places with him from my childhood
watching the Spiderman animated yeah
came out amazing spider-man number 50 I
think is way up here it was like 67 1967
or something yeah but he was originally
a spider-man villain then eventually he
becomes like a daredevil villain and
he's really kind of like back and forth
you know I don't remember exactly where
he stands right now in the current day
but I just have fingers and all the
crime around the world like well I saw
him in was during spectacular spider-man
when Goblin was taking over they blew up
kingpins building and he flip okay um
all right so the whole history kingpin
is really really cool it actually goes
back to his childhood where he was like
the fat kid basically and he was
tormented all the time so like from the
time that he was younger like he began
to learn how to manipulate people and
that he actually killed the first person
his first person when he was like 12 or
something like that like he's got a
really dark history and then from there
like he just kind of rose up through the
the crime scene and he actually became a
like he he United several gangs and
became like the number one or the
second-in-command like some crime lord
and then killed him and took over his
took over his gang and like United all
these gangs of New York and then just
eventually rose to prominence and became
like this kingpin of crime-- in in New
York City but the thing about about a
kingpin is that he's not he's not
entirely brute strength I mean he is
strong physically you know he's formable
in terms of the physical strength but
he's really really smart and he's very
capable and he will go to any lengths to
achieve whatever it is that he wants to
do so if we're gonna be singing kingpin
in a Netflix TV series I want to see
dark I want to see people dying I want
to see you know Michael Corleone
executing the heads of the five families
and Godfather kind of stuff like I want
to see some serious you know down ethics
they could do that they can but the part
of the question is will they because you
got to be honest with Captain America -
this was the first like really dark
Marvel Cinematic Universe film that we'd
seen so you know I mean up until that
point there was comedy it was relatively
light-hearted but it was it was fun to
watch this movie Captain America too was
fun to watch but it was dark I mean it
was it was there was there were themes
of you know government versus the people
and political themes and for the you
know yeah Bucky Barnes killing people I
mean it was it was a dark movie you know
for the most part as least as dark as
they've gotten so far and so I'm really
hoping that
with this movie they're gonna get down
and they were with with Netflix ears are
gonna get down and in much darker
because the kingpin in terms of his
involvement with daredevil there were no
I mean it was all pretty sinister in a
lot of ways based on the characters that
they've got that they're gonna feature
daredevil Iron Fist Luke Cage like
they're they're all like in the seedy
underbelly like on the streets yeah
they're not like you know big-time
superheroes that go off and you know
fight well hot lips or Thanos or you
know I mean they were support characters
like Luke Cage was one of the New
Avengers that came out came out with
volume 1 like he was one of the people
that was recruited after the breakout
storyline by uh by Tony Stark but or I'm
sorry by Captain America but um you know
and and iron face they're trying to make
big right now - yeah well because I
think what the Tron they're trying to to
be honest I think they're trying to tie
into the whole african-american theme in
terms of Marvel Cinematic Universe
characters because we saw that with with
Nick Fury and I think there was a lot of
outcry from people when they said like
we want Falcon we want you know Luke
Cage because there were some character
just some pretty pretty prominent roles
you know and they were interesting and
dynamic characters but um well Falcon
gets to come back with the next Captain
America yeah he's already catching on
I'm very I'm very interested okay so all
the people on my channel who are
watching this video you guys have been
screaming at me about what I said about
Falcon and Captain America - how I
didn't like his character and I feel
like he was relegated to a sidekick I
apologize my son's have been lambasted
me over there they've just been like
what are you talking about okay the
Falcon was good in Captain America - he
was interesting and I liked his
character so I guess we'll leave it at
that but but yeah you know I'm I'm
excited to see what Vincent D'Onofrio
has to offer in terms of his role as
kingpin because you know we've seen him
play some pretty sadistic characters in
the past and so I'm really kind of
hoping he can tap into that you know
Vincent D'Onofrio from Full Metal Jacket
kind of character and bring that to the
kingpin in this Netflix TV series I
don't know
well with his experiences on Law & Order
I mean he's got like almost 20 years or
at least ten or something I don't know
how long
the show has been on forever yeah but
he's got like heavy into that whole lawn
I mean I always felt like he was kind of
an evil character in that the way he
portrayed his gay I know he's a good guy
but every time I saw him always felt
like he was like a sleazy crime guy to
begin with
backdoor stuff you know yeah yeah I
could totally see that I could I mean
he's got to put weight on or muscle on
or they're gonna have to really kind of
like type out the whole thing with
kingpin and that as much as they do with
you know visual effects now think about
what they did with Chris Evans in
Captain America they made him really
small they could easily make somebody
real big that's what I was gonna say I
agree with that but at the same time if
you had seen the whole movie Chris Evans
tiny you wouldn't believe it oh yeah
that's true that's true
sometime you watch guys always head up a
little bit but I've been in fat suit I
don't know I don't really think that he
needs to be super big like as little as
he actually fights or at least it seems
that he fights I mean he doesn't he's he
the first time I ever fought daredevil I
mean that came much later on in Marvel
yeah but he doesn't he usually doesn't
fight like directly with people that
often he's usually just organized and
that's what makes a kingpin cool he's an
he's an organized crime boss you know
and he's just cutthroat and brutal so
that that's what makes him kind of
interesting I mean kingpin was never
like a top tier villain he was never
like a major showrunner and Marvel
Comics he was just kind of like he was
one of those villains that was relegated
to a comic that's isolated to a
particular character so he was he's like
the you know let's say like I don't know
like the Green Goblin of spider-man
comics like the Green Goblin is a
spider-man villain yeah I mean you never
really see the Green Goblin outside of
spider-man comics there might be
team-ups where you might appear with
other villains but you don't have like a
huge crossover event with the Green
Goblin right so you know kingpin is a
lot of the same way but I like to think
that the size of the kingpin is one of
his defining factors because they always
make fun of oh you're fat you're fat
it's all sheer muscle and what it always
every time that a superhero goes against
it but always seems to end up with them
getting to his office and being like all
right I'm gonna take you down King but
you're too fat to fight me and he's like
boom just just crushing everything
it's always kind of like his last okay
yep you got all the way to the top
because the kingpin has henchmen and
most superheroes get through those
henchmen pretty easily yeah I mean the
kingpins vulnerable like when he and
daredevil fought for the first time he
punched daredevil in the head once and
that was the end of the fight so I mean
he's a former bullfighter yeah I mean
he's got experience in boxing and as
much experience as a guy his size can
have at hand-to-hand combat but
nonetheless I mean he's to me the
defining attribute of kingpin may not
necessarily be a size it is to a degree
because he's a very powerful man and a
huge man but it's it's simply just the
the road and the methods he's willing to
do in order to get to achieve what it is
that he wants I mean do you think maybe
yeah I mean let's say like he's Vincent
D'Onofrio is not going to put on like
300 pounds no if they gave him like some
sort of technology to fight with well it
depends on the abilities I mean if he
doesn't fight if they simply say Vincent
D'Onofrio is kingpin it's just basically
gonna be like he's gonna be like Michael
Corleone from The Godfather he's gonna
be an organizer he's gonna be a leader
he's gonna be a mob boss but he's not
gonna be a fighter I don't really have a
problem with that if they properly
regulated him you know if they handled
it properly
the kingpin could just never end up in a
fight because normally he ends up in a
fight as a last resort like Rob said he
doesn't always get into the fight so it
could very easily just we go in every
other round we has a thousand 100 or
exits de body doubles and all kinds of
great stuff for that that he likes to
use we don't actually have to have him
fight I'm just saying that the size of
him is one of the things that I feel is
one of those defining factors because it
always boils down to if I do get in a
fight with them we can you know it's
gonna be a fight it's not just a I
caught him yeah you know where you are
if they put him just as like normal size
Vincent D'Onofrio in that situation I'm
pretty sure daredevil or Luke Cage or
iron fist
what would beat him and in all
likelihood it looks like there's going
to be a giant crossover event at the end
which is what I'm gonna guess is
going to be the fight with the kingpin
like what would they do aside from him
gaining a lot of weight yeah and looking
big enough to take on all three of them
or give him some sort of technology to
maybe let him stand a chance against all
three of them if they do the technology
route we're just gonna get a fan up cry
like we got with the Rhino yeah long
time because Rhino we was a big guy in
war a rhino suit like it wasn't a metal
suit it was a physical use I think I
think if they would have featured him
more and you know kind of explained a
little more why he's in that suit it
would have been okay but the fact that
he wasn't featured really all that much
well kind of I don't think the mech
Rhino would have been fed would have
been okay no matter how they explained
it cuz every version of Ryan I like Rob
said is a guy in a suit and the only
version only deviant they've made from
that that path has been an ultimate
spider-man where it was like a mutant
but he was still a big guy in what
appeared to be a rhino suit well I think
there is a rhino that does appear in
like a suit like a like a mechanical
suit but that wasn't the Rhino and even
nobody wants to see that nobody cares
about that right now
everybody wants to see Rhino like I
can't what his name is but the original
Rhino running around he's a great big
huge gigantic super strong guy and wears
like a bodysuit like a physical skin
type soon with a rhino horn on the head
like yeah everybody loves that guy I
mean everybody wants to everybody want
to see him and then I imagine that Sony
including Rhino as the at the end of
spider-man 2 the last 15 minutes so
whenever was that he was there it's
supposed to be like you know hey this is
what we're gonna do in spider-man
amazing spider-man 3 but no one cared
because by that point the movie was so
convoluted and so screwed up and it was
like watching smarter man just
unwillingly go through and just play the
role of spider-man or watching Andrew
Garfield just go through and it's kind
of mechanically play the role of
spider-man but nobody really cared that
he was gonna be in this I guess I just
don't understand how in this slightly
more realistic you know cinematic
universes that are being set up how they
would pull off a dude dressed in a giant
Rhino suit with a horn
without making it mechanical in some way
well like I know that that green goblin
kind of got genetically altered but at
the same time it's it's not like on that
level of extreme well and it would look
really corny well you would like to
think that and that's what the movie
studio is used to think which is why we
got crap superhero movies but what
Marvel finally just said look we're just
gonna make a superhero movie I mean
anybody if you wrote it down anyone
could easily say you know back when I
are making out Oh an Iron Man suits
gonna look [ __ ] on movies gonna has
to be a cartoon or something it's not
gonna work yeah it look amazing a guy
run around with a shield you if you told
me this 10 years ago they're gonna make
a Captain America movie and it's gonna
be a guy at the Captain America in
uniform with the shield running around
I'd be like you're stupid and now they
like they're two of the best films of
Marvel's made so far like to say that
best comic book films out there exactly
and how about Thor if you told me a
Norse God was gonna have a movie he was
gonna be in the hair yeah exactly and
and I mean to me this is you know this
kind of ties on one of the things we
talked about last time I think we were
talking about movies and we were talking
about subtle changes of stuff that
people make to me you know they didn't
necessarily have they don't really have
to have the Rhino dressed up as like a
guy wearing a rhino see for example to
go back to Iron Man 1 it's a little bit
different but Obadiah Stane was he had
his own company like he was a separate
guy I mean he was like a Justin Hammer
kind of guy like he was his own separate
thing and he wanted to take it he wanted
like bankrupt Tony Stark and take over
his stuff but it was a point where he
was relatively successful and kind of
running Tony Stark out of there but
eventually he came back but nonetheless
he wasn't like you know a friend of the
father and then raised Tony Stark and
ran the business until Tony Stark turned
18 it wasn't like that
you know um to me I mean I would have
been just as happy as seen you know to
see like a great big huge just like
mammoth of a man with like a black
bandanna and like a tear on his cheek
and say I'm the Rhino that would have
been fine with me because the Rhino was
just he was pure raw physical strength
as strong as a guy could be and he was
just pummel superhero a Spider Man it's
best he could but that was
really about it you know in terms of his
powers I think you're going a little
crazy with that with the Rhino thing
though because in the Euro you're both
trying to find a way to not make him
corny the Rhino is corny
in the comics he's corny here's the
shows he's corny he's a guy in a rhino
suit who has sheer strength and runs at
spider-man he has never been successful
as a solo guy that's true and then he
goes Oh Paul Giamatti as the Rhino and
his selfish are [ __ ] casting choice
and generally to get us back on casting
options yeah that's true Giamatti the
guys like 50 he's known for like you
know playing dumpy guys you're really
gonna make him this gangster in a rhino
suit all right hold on hold on hold on
now let's not go talking bad about my
Home Slice okay let me ask you would you
rather see someone like Vin Diesel in a
full Rhino suit running a spider-man or
Paul Giamatti riding in a mech both of
them are corny that mech did not look
cool Vin Diesel I would take Vin Diesel
I'm saying get someone that size for the
rod yeah the rocker so matter but but I
don't know I mean you know we were
talking bout Vincent D'Onofrio before
right yeah so so to me it's you know
because of the fact that to me kingpin
was was basically a crime lord you know
I don't mind the fact that he's not
gonna be this great big huge colossal
guy now it could be that he just builds
up and becomes big or maybe he
encounters some kind of drug that makes
him huge or maybe he just never gets big
and he's just a really good physical
fighter I'm not really sure what they
choose to do with him but you know to me
one of the biggest defining attributes
of kingpin was just how ruthless and
bloodthirsty he was and so that's what
I'm really really wanting to see in this
Netflix series is just some hardcore you
know bloodthirstiness coming from this
guy as opposed to like some kind of
toned down Michael Duncan Clarke kind of
kingpin basically you know where he
talks and he taunts and that's really
about it
so I agree with you on that one if they
could make him that if they can take
every one of his attributes to make him
this ruthless guy in charge of
everything he's just this twisted Lord
of the crime guy mm-hmm I can forgive
the lack of physical Brutus if they
don't go with it yeah so all right so
attack Baron Zemo is out of a computer
right now we gotta forgive some casting
for dr. strange
yes about this one I'll say it right now
I don't need actor choices you're naming
I don't even write I disagree with you I
do not like this casting choice
I don't really know dr. strange all that
well so I'm probably gonna end up giving
it to you but I think he's too buff hmm
to a big oh that part that I'm hearty
the guy who aim no that's not gonna work
you would if you want a good casting
choice it should have been like the
people have you seen The Prestige the
older magician guys one of them okay
the older magician guys what are you
talking about in the prestige it was a
huge Ackman yeah okay let's get it let's
get him in here no man no I don't do not
want movie the one that had the
illusionist all right here's my deal
when it comes to that's perfect sorry
I'm just saying you told Edward Norton
they perfect it since he's no longer the
Hulk let's make him dr. strange I don't
think the reason that they didn't
continue him as the Hulk was he wanted
too much money
mm-hmm it depends on what can't you talk
to supposedly he wanted too much money
but then if you talk to them they just
there's a scheduling conflict and for
the record Edward Norton hasn't been in
any other movies so that may be but Owen
I'm more inclined to think to ever
ignore and backed out due to scheduling
issues and less about the money if he
needed money we'd see him at about five
other movies already
yeah he's been in a ton of my mean he's
got he's got a huge try I'm an American
History X and he's got all kinds of
things to his name you know so um but
here's the deal and to me like one Tom
Hardy isn't a naturally huge guy like
the way that we saw him in warrior
that's not his natural physical size
like the way that we saw him in as Bain
was not a natural physical size there's
actually an interview do what is he
actually lost weight before though like
it just seems like he's been playing
more massive parts now yeah he has but
there was a interview that he had did
that he had done I came who was with
there was some British guy maybe was
Stephen Fry I don't know but he had done
an interview and he was talking about
the character warrior and in the
interview like he's small loving he's
he's not you know scrawny or anything
but he's your average size for a guy of
his age he's not a great big huge guy
but to meet like Tom Hardy can play such
amazing roles as far as I'm concerned
with regards to Tom Hardy like warrior
was one of the greatest movies I've ever
seen him playing in that movie was was
so fantastic because the depth of
character that he had was amazing he had
like all these personal diamonds that he
was struggling with so the guy cracked
yeah the guy can act and then of course
he was awesome an inception and he was
you know he was as far as a riding yo us
he was good in bein good as Bane so you
know to me I think he's a great casting
choice for Doctor Strange now my
personal opinion my personal number one
guy is Aidan Gillen the guy that plays
Littlefinger from Game of Thrones
like that's my that's my choice for
Doctor Strange but I just think I think
Tom Hardy just from looking at this and
basing entirely off it you just now
telling me that Tom Hardy was gonna be
too strange honestly Doctor Strange is
like one of the oldest guys in the
Marvel Universe he is an older guy he's
well into his 30s or 40s I think yeah
right I would go 4050 with him he's got
the way he was a very experienced
surgeon yeah so like I mean he had to
have at least 20 years of surgery under
his belt I would think I mean I don't
ever how old he was when he became when
he when he met the ancient one and
became dr. stranger you know be and
learn magic and stuff but
you know I mean let's see I mean this
for the most part all these movies are
taking place in modern era so let's say
like civil war dr. strange all right by
that point he looks like he's well into
his forties possibly even his fifties
maybe you know but again you're talking
about a sorcerer supreme yeah I could
make himself look any age so you know it
really just kind of depends on on what
it is that he has going on but 90 he's
19 years 200 years old but you know to
me given the casting choices that
they've made
they're obviously building on the on you
know Tom Hardy you know playing Bane to
kind of bring those DC fans over to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe by having him
play Doctor Strange but you know my
personal choice would be Aidan Gillen
you know if I had to choose anybody in
the world and say you're going to play
Doctor Strange it would be him because
he looks the part he's around the same
age yeah he's around the same age he's a
great actor as we've seen in Game of
Thrones now the biggest question is can
you really play anything outside of that
guy because he's a man damn you a
manipulative guy in Game of Thrones and
if you were to be transitioned and play
Doctor Strange is he one of these
characters that's been typecast now is
he like the Mark Hamill of Game of
Thrones am I gonna look at him and
anything other than Littlefinger from
Game of Thrones yeah I don't know I
think Game of Thrones is very popular
but I think there's enough people that
don't watch it it's Bo show it's why it
hasn't taken over taken over the top
slot from like walking dead and stuff
like yeah yeah Walking Dead is the
number one show I think right now but
AMC comes with cable subscription so I
don't know I mean so so we agree Tom
Hardy's not the best choice I think we
all agree in Aiden Gillen yeah we'll see
how it goes but I'm not disappointed to
see the Tom Hardy is being considered
for the role of dr. strange I thought
I'm not is he being considered or is he
been cast he's being considered he's one
of the top two people one of the two
people that they're really kind of
gunning for I camera for who the other
guy is and that's that's why it's kind
of bothered me I don't know what his
name is because I know when you first
told me like a few days ago that it was
happening I actually went on Google and
tried to find where that came from and I
couldn't find it it least not as behind
sitter that he was cast that he was
being considered or cast to my knowledge
it's it's well recognized information I
found it already
but to my knowledge like it's
well-established that Tom Hardy is one
of the top two people to be considered
are you looking it up Benny yeah I'm
trying to see right now yeah yeah but uh
while I'm looking that up though let me
ask you guys the next question because
that's that's one thing you want to talk
about we also want to talk about Josh
Brolin right Yeah right anis yeah but
let me ask you on a quick note because
we don't have much on it how do you feel
about them changing directors on ant-man
oh not just changing directors the
director leaving because of disputes
with Marvel this lends credence to
actually a few other arguments that
people have made to like Terrence Howard
like the word around the campfire the
rumor mill is I've heard it is that
Terrence Howard didn't know that he
wasn't gonna be an Iron Man to you until
he saw Don Cheadle playing Rhodes and
Iron Man - that's how we found out you
know that's what I've heard
I don't know that's I mean there's no
like like you said with with Edward
Norton and you know depending on who you
talk to there are some people say that
he wanted too much money and they said
we're not gonna give it to you you know
I mean it depends on who you talk to
some people say different things but
crazy they live right yeah they go
absolutely nuts so yeah you know to me I
don't know but the fact that there were
disputes I mean we don't know what the
disputes were for the most part like we
don't know really what all was going on
you know so it could just be that that
you know they had a difference of
opinion on the creative aspect of how it
is that we should a man it could will
and and you know Marvel wants to go a
certain direction exactly they they have
probably strict guidelines for what is
supposed to be in that movie yeah and if
the director just didn't like them
having that much control and wanted to
do his own thing but it was gonna make
the whole cinematic universe spin off
you know and into a direction Marvel
didn't want to go
yeah Marvel doesn't want to end up in
the x-men boat well they're rebooting
the whole thing because they like
everyone go make their own movie and
yeah because they've come so far with
all the moves they've done it'd be a
shame to have to go back and basically
like reboot the last one like five or
six years worth of movies that have been
sure they will there hopefully won't be
any times 6 2007
okay so about seven years or something
like that yeah for what I'm hearing this
guy had already written me a transcript
like ten years ago he's been trying to
get them to make this movie for like ten
years hmm
and he's leaving because Marvel I've
been like David said I have a feeling
Marvel has a idea of what they want to
make it match and if you were to script
ten years ago that's not gonna match if
you're trying to do a cinematic universe
and this guy's got a preset I want to do
this ant-man movie then no I mean yeah
we don't I mean it could be that when he
wouldn't approach Marvel with the script
he was like I want Hank Pym to be the
one that creates Ultron and why what
could have said nope Tony Stark is the
forerunner he's the front-runner for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe he's gonna be
the one that creates Ultron in the as
well I'm just not gonna direct the movie
then and walked away they could've done
something as simple as that and he was
like no I'm making an ant-man movie
exactly the ant-man movie actually was
never supposed to be Hank Pym there were
supposed to be Stephen Lang who was I
think it is I think they're avoiding
yeah super secret thing like they could
even make a Hank Pym character for
Avengers 2 now I'm not saying because I
know Benny's read the first 20 minutes
of of Avengers 2 but if they were to
create a Hank Pym character and have
them you know partner with Tony Stark
partner with mr. fantastic or whatever
and make Ultron like they did in the
comics hmm then they could still do that
because the ant-man in the movie is the
jokester like thief who steals Hank Pym
technology right yeah could be a hold we
don't really know where it's going in
this we really though due to time
constraints and since we're kind of just
kind of pulling a straws on the ant-man
thing I'd like to get in Josh Brolin
because we are 52 minutes on the podcast
and where are the viewers have suggested
between an hour an hour and a half yeah
and if we're still kids talk about
Avengers 2 and I've got all the comments
pulled up so we can go through them also
yes okay so um so let's go to your Josh
Brolin discussion you all week have been
like we need my head about Josh Brolin
banana wanting to talk about josh brolin
so much all right so like 4 a.m. for you
all right so so I'm really excited to
see this I love Josh Brolin as an actor
he is he's like No Country for Old Men
is one of my top 5 favorite movies of
all time like I love that movie it's
such a great film and now Josh Brolin
doesn't necessarily have the greatest
track record in terms of movies that
he's made because he's been in movies
like mimic and he was the the kid who
was an [ __ ] and The Goonies so you
know I mean he was he's been around for
a while
but up until No Country for Old Men like
I didn't really take him seriously that
movie came out and then I took him
seriously and for the most part do what
I mean on my legally obtained videos
yeah you guys saw that but that was that
was a good movie and like I expected to
go into that movie like alright they're
just gonna slay that's what I thought
it'd be push that's what I can like by
the end of it like you generally felt
sorry for him yeah like you like left
that movie theater like whoa yeah but um
because he was a good actor in that he
was mad he was that uh but to me like I
I am very excited to see this and and
the whole reason for this is because
Josh Brolin in No Country for Old Men
portrayed himself as a very serious guy
like he was a serious no mess around
former Vietnam veteran kind of guy so
yeah he's exactly exactly so like to me
he perpetrates great characters and
Thanos is a dynamic and serious and
hardcore guy and Marvel Comics and so I
really couldn't think of anybody better
to play the role than Josh Brolin
initially I thought they were gonna CGI
and I actually saw this I saw this this
link on Facebook it was a turn out to be
a joke but they said they cast on with
sports and I got to play the role of fan
I think it'll be great cast
now my only question is this why wasn't
dannis Cassie because we have a
different guy that plays in when the
Avengers mid-credits scene mm-hmm well
then I think I think was just all CGI he
turns the camera and grins yeah no
apparently I looked it up he's bait like
the voice and the face is rendered over
someone well I mean that's not in common
like I mean you remove that show heroes
yeah yeah okay
until Zachary Quinto showed up and
actually was playing the role of Sylar
he was played by two or three different
guys I think so it's silent yes I later
sonic cuz I mean up until Zachary Quinto
popped up like you never saw his face
yeah you was always just kind of out oh
yes he was in shadow and some of it was
just different people but nonetheless um
I mean that to me doesn't seem to to
awful I'm glad they're doing this now
and actually cashing Thanos as a guy
that's going to continue playing the
role of Thanos and so waiting so like
after guardians of the galaxy and saying
oh my god thatis it's popular let's just
actually cast somebody to play him
instead of having different people play
his character but you know again I'm not
at all upset about this um this is I
think probably one of the best casting
choices they have made in terms of
characters to play the role of Thanos
because I think that Josh Brolin is a
stellar actor in a lot of different ways
so it's better than you know DC's
choices on characters yeah it's like I
said earlier Marvel's picking guys that
are pretty well known but they're not
you know this yeah well they're not
they're not the types that are like
absolutely 100% like oh we're gonna like
typecast this person yeah or oh this
person is really super popular right now
exactly I'm and I like that element I
like it when they come along and they
say we don't want great big huge guys to
play roles because I mean think about
the role of Nick Fury let's assume for
example that they didn't have Samuel
Jackson they they just they didn't sign
the contract that Samuel Jackson made
him sign and they said if he said you
want to keep using the ultimate version
of me yes let me play the movie so let's
say that that never happened and Marvel
has a blank slate on who it is they
could play the role of Nick Fury and
Marvel Comics you've got all kinds of
different characters they could play
that role you've got major actors that
could have filled that role hell you
could have had Kevin Spacey play that
role if they really wanted to but
there's a difference and I'm kind of I'm
with Vinnie on this there's a difference
between simply making a film and saying
let's get the biggest names we possible
and just kind of forcing them in there
and man the film feel the thumb feels
force as opposed to just great casting
choices here's another thing is like
normally like when you see these huge
movies that all have like huge groups of
like giant actors in the industry on set
it seems like they don't have the same
like mindset about being a part of a
team they all want to stand out in the
movies so they all try to overact or
they'll like create giant problems on
the set and like Marvel what they do
seems to work pretty well because
they're all fairly big actors like you
said but they're not huge enormous
actors that are all going to expect to
be the star in the movie they're not
walking in there expecting top billing
from their role they're getting but see
the difference is in the Marvel stuff
they're all getting their separate top
billing mm-hmm you know and then then
they're just supposed to come together
it's a part almost a part of the Contra
hey you're gonna get three movies where
you're like he's a star to Chris Evans
you just have to play ball with everyone
else during these the team-up
yeah but it's building it's building up
to that I mean you had Iron Man one with
Robert Downey jr. come back to fill me
at Iron Man to where he was making
millions of dollars you had iron man 3
you had Captain America 1 Captain
America 2 and then you had of course
like Black Widow Scarlett Johansson and
Jeremy Renner okay now all right all
right let's slide Chuck for a second I'm
gonna talk guys yeah again I want to
talk to you guys real quick and I guess
we'll finish this up before we get into
into Avengers The Avengers 2 portion
what do you guys think about Jeremy
Renner playing Hawkeye I've been
thinking about it's a good casting yeah
you put Hawkeye in at least give him the
mask even if he's not gonna wear it yes
have it around it's on his back he
throws it on oh I can't see well that
was stupid about it yeah something yeah
well I think I think he deserved more of
a feature and there was was some you
know postings about that how Jeremy
Renner didn't like that he was basically
like a
zombie like the entire length of
Avengers so I'm hoping they give him
either his own feature film at some
point or we haven't gotten one he's got
he's at his own comic he's just like or
a black widow and in park I'm like that
was the rumors going around awhile ago
but now she now she's getting a movie on
some totally different thing yeah it's I
can't with that but but that's okay
that's what I was gonna say like to me I
felt like Jeremy Renner plays a great
Hawkeye and I felt like he has just kind
of been relegated like they just kind of
shuffled him to the back and just said
you just stay back here and let us worry
about what's going on up here
like I didn't like that like Hawkeye has
some big roles in in Marvel Comics I
don't know if he you uh did you ever
read Avengers disassembled me I haven't
yet I'm sorry Dave yeah yeah I know
Vinnie said that he read it but you
haven't read it yet Dave I am ready yeah
okay Hawkeye is pretty important in
Avengers disassembled like there's a big
moment with him in that in that comic
and in house of him there's an equally
big moment with him so you know Hawkeye
played some pretty big roles and I'm he
was an Avenger you know in the comics
thing he was a big-time Avenger he was
one of the main Avengers you know so you
know it's it's when you look at him I
mean Hawkeye was part of West Coast
Avengers too I think
but what do you yeah when you look at
his character like he's had some great
roles in Marvel Comics and I felt like
he just wasn't represented very well and
the movies I just kind of shuffled him
to the back and and so I'm really hoping
that an Avengers 2 and I think that he
is I'm hoping he gets a lot more screen
time and he gets a lot more like upfront
you know standing next to Tony Stark and
Captain American those guys instead of
kind of standing you know back into the
left you know so I mean you know I'm
really kind of hoping they do more with
this character but I just want to see
what you guys thought about that if you
guys you know how you guys felt about
Jeremy Renner and how they've done
Hawkeye in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
yeah I think he needs a movie I think he
finally does anyone mm-hmm awesome okay
so uh so I'm sure the subscribers have
been dying for this you know I know I
have well actually because I don't want
because I don't want to spoil the people
who are trying to avoid it let's go to
the comments real quick and then instead
of going over a character we'll go over
the script stuff that I found so that
okay so uh comments because remember we
asked for comments so we can respond to
them I'm going down
top comments down we'll probably go like
five or six from down to thing how much
time we discuss each one
ratchet says great idea guys David just
needs to be more vocal but it's a great
mix just want to asked with a far from
each other that you already answered him
and then the follow-up states that the
DC guy cuts off David quite a bit you
get Scarlett Johansson's so you're not
really gonna upset me with these
comments and we are taking these as ways
to fix the podcast okay
there's quite a few comments in here
about me cutting off Rob or cutting off
David and when we talk about comics this
is one of the few things that I get
insanely excited about the and so that
and that's that's why I get it I just
get crazy and I just start talking but
we are taking your comments and trying
to fix it so I do apologize to people
who have complained about that one guy
said that he had to pause the video four
times because he couldn't stand me
because he couldn't stand me and okay
you know when you for like two years
guys you're not gonna offend me alright
here's the deal guys like all you guys
my subs I love you guys but you know hey
these podcasts are fun I mean if you
guys don't enjoy your buddy on the
podcast and I guess just don't watch it
I mean you know man I don't mean to be a
dick you know I don't mean to be an
[ __ ] to you guys I love you guys but
you know I mean like don't be a dick so
we are trying to get a nice mix Rob is
the calm guy who knows the serious you
know more obscure stuff I'm the insane
guys who likes to think watch things
blow up and you know I that's what I
like to watch so I get a little crazy
David's the guy that brings up legit
points and goes into a lot more in-depth
stuff because he hasn't been reading
comics as long as me Rob yeah so but we
are trying to get a nice mix I do not
did not cut I agree I don't I do have to
not have cut off Rob or David and stuff
like that but you know you can be nicer
buddy baby crying been coming off again
Benny watch what happens
I'll come through that camera so moving
through that and David has been a lot
more vocal this episode so he's just got
to find his own he's not used to doing
this stuff like us I don't know what
this is about but Darkseid here who says
that somebody has a seriously nice ass
and then you laughed about it Rob so
maybe you know what I mean I don't I had
no idea what he was talking about
somebody's darks a hero please explain
who's a seer join yeah apparently Greg
let Gregory Colson and gets stuck buying
comic books every week I'm hoping this
week he won't get stuck buying comic
books we didn't talk about comic books
we didn't like a whole bunch of Deadpool
comic books I think you say I love that
guy's comments but I got cracks me up
we really appreciate your comments and
we're really glad that we're helping you
pick out the comic books and we're
hoping you're enjoying them so at least
you're not spending $70 and stuff you
don't enjoy exactly apparently
apparently I'm wrong because I said I
wasn't gonna be apocalypse but Starkid
Potter has is giving me the link here
for Age of Apocalypse stating that it
will be Age of Apocalypse or at least
partially about a bit so if the last
week you were saying I was hoping it
wouldn't be I didn't think they would do
to reset the world events yeah I guess
we're doing to reset the world events is
there they've got two movie series now
too though don't they
no no the other ones gone they're just
doing first class on work oh okay I've
also been corrected because gum by
Garcia says Fantomex killed apocalypse
aka Kid Omega yes I saw they and for the
record I did a disclaimer in stated that
I read that like five years ago and I
could barely remember it so I'm just
disclaim to that one immortal be says DC
Comics sucks
I think immortal beast sucks
double Hilo says loves the podcast guys
nearly two-hour length is great because
it allows us to ramble and go on our
tangents but still talking about the
topics that we announce we're going to
cover their question is hard to phrase
maybe you guys cannot be sorted out when
it comes to superhero teams do you think
characters and those teams are better
served when they're established solo
heroes who come together aka the
Avengers and Justice League or do you
like it when they're designed to be a
team like the x-men hmm ah man that's a
good question it depends on how the
characters are done the x-men are great
because they came together in a way
where they were written where they were
like our mutant powers manifested at
puberty and we don't know what to do
with them and so Professor Xavier was
like I will teach you what you need to
know and how to control them that was
the foundation for the x-men that's how
the hitch-pin reformed no more less and
because Xavier encountered the Shadow
King and past life so nonetheless you
know if it was the team was designed to
be that way the Avengers and especially
like what we see with the New Avengers
when Tony Stark talks to Iron Man and
wants to reform the Avengers after
Avengers disassembled he says we need
the Avengers back because there are some
threats that we just have to have that
we have to have Avengers 4 because
they're just so big that we you know we
know one person can defeat them on their
own
um now if he's talking about like the
movies I'm not really sure where to go
with the movies I but I mean I agree
VIII kind of like depending on the rib
eye like the giant team books because
when you had heroes that are on their
own like Justice League I was never a
big Superman fan at the new 52 I didn't
like super me because use too much of a
boy scout I honestly felt like every
time Superman got into a fight or
whatever it was always resolved with
brute strength is his weakness was
always group tonight and there was
really nothing more to the character
then I want Lois Lane I ignored all of
his Tom's books at the new 52 launch I
started reading the Justice League
because they had flash Green Lantern a
Batman three of my favorite DC heroes in
it and I got to know Superman through
that and he has his own books yeah now
I'm reading Superman books so I think
it's a great thing when they when they
bring those teams together but like Rob
said the x-men was built to be that way
yeah that's a great book and some of
those characters as great as they are I
don't see holding up on a book on the
road yeah yeah there's some courage
there's only a few and it's the few that
they have look on their own already you
know you know a great example of a
fan favorite that I don't think could
hold a whole book a long-term on his own
Iceman Iceman is a great support
character great comedic character the
background he could do a limited run I
could see that but as like a permanent
like a Wolverine book I don't see it
going very far I mean he's no he's a
super powerful character he's an
omega-level character but yeah I agree
with you man I would not consistently
buy Ice Man comics he's got too many
weaknesses it seems like I know you say
it's a level but I mean fire oh my god
someone pushed me into a fireplace I'm
dead your favorites do you like them
when they're already established and put
together or do you like just team books
oh really I mean like you said I don't
think there's some characters that
really couldn't stand on their own I
think that there's there's some
characters in the x-men that that could
potentially stand on their own but I
like I like teen books hey I like
crossover events I like like you said
the Avengers you know they handle things
that are too big for you know just
single you know heroes to handle on
their own you know like Fantastic Four I
don't think they anyone on their own
could face Galactus yeah banded together
and they face Galactus so yeah I think
there's a reason for okay um
Gregory Clausen also correct system
stating that phantom X killed kid a kid
apocalypse so I will never be wrong
again guys I will always make sure I
have every week Ian
dynamite Christgau god that's the Wonder
one we keep saying is there girl that
plays Wonder Woman that's a good thing
I've got is nobody expects me to have
universal knowledge about anything yeah
Gumby Garcias isn't unknowing zebra here
we should keep the thing at 30 minutes
because he had to pause the podcast 4
times to get
ruin he wants a 30 minute podcast cuz
I'm so annoying well as the one guy who
says that you're annoying I think I
think we're okay for the most part I
have plenty those on my channel - hey
you're annoying stop being annoying I
used to do when we first started doing
the video game channel it's a funny
little Side Story for two seconds when I
first did the metal gear solid story I
would talk about it like welcome to the
Medicus l story blah blah blah blah and
when I would read the script I would try
to be big boss oh okay
so the big boss calling I am such a
divided fanbase over that that like hate
it I love it I hate it I love it
everything like normal but I yeah I got
okay oh here we go
I didn't I didn't catch this when I was
going through previously um oh hey let
me interrupt you for a second Benny is
it just me or is Benny's camera really
Pixley yeah I don't know I think is an
internet connection isn't good yeah I
think it's they just said your internet
was crap out there no overall this guy
people start to degrade as we go on oh
yeah that actually happens to my
girlfriend and I like so she ends up
being really pixelated huh
what is that cuz this comment right here
goes exactly we were talking about today
and I think you already talked about it
but Ben Affleck bought his weight into
the batman bruce wayne role i've heard
that that makes me more scared about it
so so what do you want to be sipping up
the call no no I mean unless you want to
have it don't matter to me we've got
over an hour of mean on pixilated limit
and somebody comments we love to comment
guys if you're one of the top voted will
be going through them cuz it makes I
guess I've gone through here and here
this guy fully spent it Fantomex shot
young apocalypse all every while
everyone was concluding that they should
not kill him Banamex felt so bad that he
cloned young apocalypse in the world and
hit him into the point where he could
enroll in the Jean Grey school encourage
Wolverine an x-men that's where he is
right now
quinton queer was currently struggle II
miss print out that non-stop witness
wire yeah Twitter
but now they're trying to stop me for
becoming his true danger with the
Phoenix like you were saying yeah all
right so um right there cuz I they could
keep going down and we could be here all
day
yeah yeah okay so you want it don't you
Rob what the Avengers script oh yeah
okay okay so we have been I have been
looking forward to this there's two
scripts because I did the search for the
script to kind of reaffirm what I'd read
about it and there's there's a pages in
the middle of it that are also like leak
I guess like the whole thing's been
leaked out for the most part so when I
read was the first 20 minutes of what's
supposedly going to happen now for quick
disclaimer this is the moment if you
want to leave leave a comment down below
say how I see if you liked it or not
I'm comic story and that's Rob from
Marvel explained that's David from
comics reviews and you will see you guys
next week
but we're gonna go into potential
spoilers for Avengers 2 so this is your
quick disclaimer alright so from what
I've read it's gonna pick up right after
Winter Soldier it's there the Avengers
are going to invade the base where
they've got the staff from Loki okay
they're gonna break in and what's gonna
it's gonna turn into a fight between
from what I've read and bear buying guys
I might be completely wrong this is all
speculation and all early drafts of a
script um he's got the staff and he's
got everything from Loki there and
they're gonna use it to fight against
things and they're gonna use the staff
to mind-control the Hulk and the Hulk is
gonna think like one of the Leviathans
is still alive from the battle back in
New York Wow
so the hoax gonna go on a massive
rampage which is then get a free Scarlet
Witch and Quicksilver and then they're
gonna fight with the Avengers right
there right there right at the beginning
of the whole thing Wow
huh because they're kind of in those
like sell things because of the Baron
right now at the end of its supposed to
pick up right at the end of Winter
Soldier
okay so right when we saw Baron von
Strucker say it was like fools or
whatever yeah Wow for it supposedly it
picks up right there
breakin right there did you say
Hulkbuster armor are they supposed to be
a nice armor wasn't discussed at all
because it looked like it was supposed
to be in the movie three well they're
gonna mind-control the Hulk at the
beginning and make him think this is
love Ivan maybe the whole Buster armor
does show up from what I've read they
don't explain how they stop the Hulk but
I guess it turns into a big 20-minute
fight of everyone fighting against the
hall to calm him down and he's trying to
fight this make-believe Leviathan well
that's how I guess Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver
I guess they get involved in the fight
but it doesn't say what happens to them
afterwards maybe these other pages do so
after they win this fight everyone then
goes back and they all apparently
they're all joking around a celebration
for winning again and it's implied that
Bruce Banner and Scarlet wit and the
Scarlet Witch
what's your name Black Widow are
together but Bruce Banner doesn't want
to Hulk out and hurt her so they're
together and then du skulle Johansson is
getting around in these movie taking
terms trying to lift Mounier uh-huh so
they're all joking I'm trying to lift it
what what the script that everyone's
read says is that Captain America can't
even budget so everyone's wondering if
they're gonna change that Wow yeah yeah
that's a big thing yeah but you know
literally the Hulk you sheer force Wow
yeah if I remember correctly Captain
America was one of like Captain America
beta ray bill and across the earth
yeah yeah and the crossovers Superman
was able to do it but there were only a
handful of people who could actually
lift Thor's hammer right so they're all
joking around drinking doing that when
you find out that a Thor's broken up
with Jane Foster right off the bat like
during this little sequence he's there
anymore and they seem to be okay with it
like I guess is some kind of like mutual
thing whoa
and Bruce Banner is with her and
Scarlett Johansson so that that's
apparently the first 20 minutes of the
movie they all fight the Hulk they all
go down there and fight Baron von
Strucker they free Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver it's a big superhero battle
right at the opening of the whole thing
Wow and then never all Joker done
drinking in the Avengers tower so so you
were saying captain or cake and butch he
can't I said so far in the scripts he
can't and now everyone's
he's saying baby no writer so he punches
in a little it implies that he can pick
it up eventually you know I mean to my
knowledge kind American never struggled
he was he never struggle to pick up
Thor's hammer he was just able to pick
it up that is man like that Debbie aw so
they had that in Avengers 2 you were
like he walked someone just picks up
Thor's hammer there's no one that I've
read but this is close okay so if a
word-for-word from what this is what I
read okay so that way can get my errors
fix up the opening sequence is a
highlight of these rumors okay a pick up
after the proposed credits scene from
Captain America witness soldier left
over left off the Avengers team up to
fight Baron von Strucker who has
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch by his
side so it is a fight between them all
anyway Hulk smash smash see strength
wins the day and leads to a party at the
Avengers tower they cut out the
apparently Capote supposedly where they
fight Hulk is for 15 minutes of that
because he supposedly thinks a Leviathan
so life you know one of the giant things
yeah they which leads to a party at the
Avengers tower where everyone tries to
pick up Thor's hammer to no avail except
Captain America who moves it just a
little bit I thought it was Hulk but
okay so apparently Captain America can
budget meanwhile Bruce Banner and Black
Widow will apparently be having feelings
for each other but Hulk is afraid of his
rage being too much for her to handle
and speaking of love Thor is now on the
market with Jane moving on Wow
and there is this assumption as Natalie
Portman is done with comic book movie
that's why they're doing it oh I could
see them doing this like oh you know
fighting a bunch of aliens that are
super powerful and they ever used you
against me and my hat keeps moving my
mouse yeah it keeps hitting the core I
to get a wireless mouse keeps hitting
the cord and moving my mouse there's
also a scene floating around now I will
act out the scene it's a one page of the
script okay come on I'm gonna you're
gonna act this out I'm gonna act all
scream it's Jarvis I do not require
additional illumination to see you Tony
and then we have Stark
yes yes we planned the I'm wearing my
sunglasses at night game we played the
I'm wearing my sunglasses at night game
before just
the lights on Jarvis I've seen you for
many years I've watched you and reached
the only possible conclusion you are the
most intelligent member of your species
start to begins to sense that something
is amiss and starts working with the
controls Stark I didn't program you for
flattery Jarvis are you angling for
another Ram upgrade Jarvis unfortunately
you are illogical your actions are
illogical Stark what are you talking
about
Jarvis your order you are you ordered
the destruction of 217 automatons
robotic armors devices that could have
protected 12.2 45 of your cities and
saved countless lives and you did so in
order to increase your chances of pare
coupling with miss Potts I must conclude
therefore that it is the pinnacle of
your human races illogical and your
species as a whole isn't a large slab
start now knows something is amiss he
attempts to vamp vamp he attempts to
vamp while working the controls to
override Jarvis's control of the lab
start come on Jarvis it's about the hold
Buster armor I know that one was your
favorite is your armor yeah I'm reading
this one for the first time so Jarvis
that is a human concept I will confess
however that I did not completely follow
the cleanslate protocol Stark raises an
eyebrow Jarvis I kept one suit of my own
design would you like to see it nice
absolutely he fumbles for his Avengers
communicator
a door in the lab raises and the lights
increase sitting in the bays a suit of
silver armor unlike any any of the
previous Iron Man suits Jarvis I call it
the Mark II of v Stark that's sort of a
radical new that's a sort of a radical
new look for me isn't it
Jarvis the mark you 5 is not for you
Tony crackle of electricity is the you
five powers up and a red arc reactor in
its chest and pulsing energy red energy
in its mouth and eyes the suit takes a
step forward and in a voice one octave
deeper than the but the but the still
recognize one octave deeper than but
still recognizable as Jarvis Ultron it
is for me
Wow Ultron reaches for stark energy
pulsing through his fingertips and seen
that's pretty badass that's pretty
awesome easily be a fanfiction though I
don't care that was good I don't care if
if you wrote that whoever you happen to
be anonymous individual out on the
internet trolling the entire interwebs
that was awesome
somebody successfully troll the Internet
if that turns out to be faking oh man
yes that's it it's a single page and the
guy who's put it out there I guess that
one's fooling around and then the other
stuff that I already read off is
floating around and the guy that really
leaked that page says my college
roommate is a visual effects artist in
California he worked on Avengers
prometheus avatar excetera mostly a
digital set designer his company is now
doing previz work for Avengers 2
storyboarding and concepts and they've
been working on early drafts for a few
key scenes he sent me this and told me
it's a pre title scene for the movie no
clue if it's real but it does it does
tie into the leak about Jarvis going
haywire and the humor seems to be like
it seems like we hmm so that's what we
got
Jarvis going crazy turns into Ultron
apparently awesome hey that makes sense
to me I mean that's good to me I mean it
kind of makes sense to a degree because
of the colors Wow well in the comics
like when Ultron first showed up like
supposedly it was it was Jarvis who was
giving who was issuing orders and he was
the mastermind behind like the Avengers
being captured and so this makes perfect
sense actually
alright the state that Ultron was made
by Tony or anything just that he the
ultra you know Jarvis made the must yeah
yeah that's all Jarvis may have just
gone awry or effective device number
yeah awesome alright guys well um if
that's it then I guess we're gonna go
ahead and bring this podcast to an end
but yeah for this week you can put
anything out any plans I'm still
checking out what might be my first book
I kind of want to skip over like I'm
gonna be you know covering basically you
know good starter books for certain
characters or
certain groups but I kind of want to
skip over the origin stories because
those are kind of obvious mm-hmm this is
the start um so I'm still getting that
out there but it's probably going to be
either one book or three books to get
started on a character can't figure it
out yet okay good stuff
what's happening right here this week at
Marvel explained Rob Marvel explained um
actually I think it's probably already
up right now but uh Civil War part twos
coming up or if it's not up now than it
will be but it'll be up by the time this
podcast gets uploaded so um that's see
that's pretty much about any another
vlog or two just kind of talking about
random stuff with you guys and yeah next
week we'll kick back off with some more
Civil War stuff alright
and uh over a comic story and I'm gonna
be wrapping up the Infinity storyline
today Oh probably tomorrow or Saturday
it depends on how much work I can get
done on it today that's they're gonna
wrap up a few elements to it and then
I'm gonna be doing another you know your
universe for the Marvel Universe next
week I'm gonna go through your guys
suggestions in the comments and I
haven't really decided what big book I'm
doing next week but good stuff other
than that I think leave your comments
down below we will go through them in
the next episode and pick out stuff and
unless there's another Avengers 2 script
leak we'll go ahead and do a live catch
you up in a character kind of thing -
yeah awesome alright well uh yeah so
we'll cut you guys later alright thanks
guys